What's the best approach to managing people that outperform you?
Okay.
I think this is a simple question as well.
What you do in this situation is you give them all the support you can and let
them run.
I'm,
I'm happy if someone's outperformed me.
That's great.
You know what else I'll do?
Try and learn from them and see what they're doing.
Try and spread the word.
If I'm in a leadership position and someone's doing outperforming everyone,
great.
How can we take that?
How can we teach to everyone else?
How can I give them supports?
They can run even faster.
This is no factor to me.
I love it.
You should be surrounding.
The more people you can bring on your team that outperform you,
the better you're going to do.
True
check.
Easy money.
Next question.
Next.
Yeah.
It's hard though.
You know,
and I know you're going to say,
oh,
am I going to say it?
That voice,
is it not true?
We know it's your ego.
It's a hundred presenting ago.
When you can't support somebody that's doing better than you.
It's 100% ego.
Why else would you not support them?
They're helping the team win.
You're helping everyone do better.
Why would you not support them?
Because your ego,
because you're like,
Ooh,
that hurts.
Yeah,
I want to be the guy.
And you know what you look like.
Then you look like a jealous baby little baby or the day baby.
You literally look jealous little baby because you're trying to hold them back
and everyone can see it and everyone can tell it.
Just don't be that person,
man.
That's a good point right there.
Everyone can tell that.
Everyone can see what's going on.
It's one of those dichotomies is,
is that people can be so ignorant to things and yet so perceptive to things.
So,
and the things like that,
they're so perceptive to echo,
doesn't like to see Jocko out shine him.
That's why he's trying to hold them back.
Oh,
he's not sending him on that trip.
We're just going to wait and when that deal,
oh,
he's going to go instead.
Yeah.
Hey,
I won the deal guys.
Yeah,
I'm great.
No wrong.
And even down to the smallest little things like that,
you know,
hey,
um,
you know,
I don't know.
We'll see.
John is the guys your subordinate,
right?
You're jealous level cause he's cause he's dope.
And when someone gives John a compliment about how good he did,
just the little looking on your face.
So obviously you don't know,
you know how you say some people are or people are so ignorant of some things
and still perceptive.
They're ignorant about this stuff when it places them [inaudible] somebody else
is like,
yeah,
you know,
I'll point those out all day.
Good points.
Like when people need,
I got this Sam Harris,
he pointed,
he had this example where name dropping when you're,
you know,
when you,
when you do some name dropping,
not everyone,
but most people,
it's like,
it's easier to recognize it when other people need a job done when they do
themselves.
You know,
so funny.
It's all true.
And there's,
if I name drop I immediately feel like a flush of just disgust.
Oh my God,
I just did that.
Oh that's so bad.
Yet it's true.
So bad.
But it's hard to kind of,
you know,
speaking of that,
I was just texting back and forth with Tim Ferris and Joe Rogan the other day
named job.
I'm just kidding.
That's how you know that's a,
that's um,
excessive name drop.
When you say their first and their last name,
that's it.
You know,
and then we'll,
I don't know what's worse.
Hey knows I was just texting.
I just got a text from Tim.
He was letting me know about that.
Yeah,
you're right.
Tim.
Who?
Tim Ferris.
Joel Hogan,
my boy.
We were kicking it old school that's like,
I'm like pseudo advanced name dropping where,
where you say the first name like that but like,
like amateur name dropping his first and last name.
So I was actually black belt name dropping first name.
First name base.
Yeah.
Actually more like one straight white belt.
You know,
it's just a little bit more advanced.
It's still name dropping is,
what's the height?
Is there a way to appropriately name drop somehow?
How do you do that?
I,
I'm sure there is,
say their name.
I was talking to someone the other day,
so this is a similar situation.
I was talking to,
you know,
met some people the other day and,
and,
and the girl says,
you will,
you know,
oh yeah,
we were talking about the east coast and she said,
Oh yeah,
I went to college,
I went to college in Cambridge and it was,
you know,
it's a good place.
And I was thinking myself,
I didn't,
I,
you know,
Oh,
where'd you go to school?
No,
we'll leave it at that.
But that was sort of a high level job.
I lived in Cambridge.
That's where I went to college.
Yeah.
One fruit and crawling.
Just talk about going on out there.
Right,
right.
So I'm just,
you know,
oh,
what's that?
A high level.
Was it or was that just an honest conversation?
It might've been,
just might've been just her not wanting to sound like,
you know,
hey,
right.
She didn't want to,
she didn't essentially want to name drop for the reason that people normally
named job.
But here's,
I think there is a weighted at like effectively in like legitimately if,
for lack of better term name drop.
And that's like if you,
if you cause name dropping,
typically speaking,
you know,
it's almost like a weak attempt at breezing over,
I'm fixing with Joel Rogan,
you know,
or they'll like say their little credentials,
you know?
But I think if you say,
you know,
I was texting with my friend and he was actually Joe Rogan,
you know that.
And you make it like a point and concise like that,
not the,
this wasn't just anyone who was Joe,
you're actually excited about it.
Yes.
You know?
Exactly.
So that,
I think that's an effective way,
cause it Kinda,
you kinda can maintain your humility there.
But you know,
when people were like,
you're just texting with my boy,
Joe Rogan,
whatever kind of thing,
we're like,
I'm just no deal.
No big deal.
It'd be deeper.